mehrere qureshi wohnt in der altstadt
von bern
sozusagen im herzen der schweiz ihr
erstes buch hat sie auf deutsch
geschrieben obwohl sie als kind in ihre
familie nur türkisch gesprochen hat
damals lebte mehr akkurat in paris in
der zweitgrößten stadt des kosovo ihre
familie gehört der türkischen minderheit
albaner türken und serben wohnten
jahrhundertelangen nachbarn nicht zu
sagen
die türkischen märchen und gebete
gedichte und geschichten waren
allgegenwärtig in mehr als familie bis
zum core soc
im alter von neun jahren kam er in ein
anderes land eine andere kultur mit
einer anderen sprache ein schock möchte
man meinen
er schaut der hängt mit der familie
daheim fühlt man sich aber vermehrt dass
die hellen fühlen mit viel mit dem
ortsteil sondern mit belegte mit familie
meine familie ist stark
menschen
zum daheim fühlen gehören auch die
geschichten im kopf einen größeren hatte
sie auf türkisch tagebücher geschrieben
geschichten zwischen realem und
erfundenem heute schreibt mehr
akkuleistung cafés alte fotos und
tagebücher sind ihr ein erinnerungs
steinbruch sowie dieses erste tagebuch
auf deutsch
nachher nachmittag bin ich mit meinem
mit alt in bern dann haben wir im
mcdonald's gegessen und dann hat meine
mutter mir eine wie eine koffer kleinen
koffer drin hat das chips coca cola und
hamburger gehabt und dann haben wir mit
dem auto zu hause gefahren
die geschichte macht mehr als erzählerin
ist schwer fassbar mal eine junge frau
mal ein kleines mädchen mal ein
flüchtlingskinder fantasierten reisen
zurück in die alte heimat zu den
elefanten im garten wo die
flüchtlingsfamilie einst wohnte
so verbindet mehr als buch vieles
miteinander erfundenes mit realem
europäisches mit orientalischem erzählen
die schweizer wirklichkeit mit einem
leben in briefen wie es möglich gewesen
wäre dort in meinem ersten leben habe
ich mit israel gelebt wäre mir jetzt
fremd erscheint er heute ein kind
bekommt vater wird
ismail mit dem ich den ganzen tag
verstecken gespielt habe
neben dem ich geschlafen habe er
existiert nur wie ich ihn zurück lasse
als kind
es ist ein buch vom auswandern und
einwander an abschied
und anfang und es bleibt offen welches
von beidem der leser gerade vor sich hat
am ende steht es war einmal
es war einmal ein schluss der alles
möglich macht auch das scheinbar
unmögliche wie ein neues leben in einem
anderen land